so Patrick I guess the headline from
this is that the bank has clearly been
too pessimistic but with its growth
forecasts why do you think that was was
that by accident or design well I don't
think we know exactly where there was
accident at all design but it was
certainly completely wrong in common
with the Treasury and all the kind of
establishment economists and the
consensus they all said brexit would
damage the economy and growth rate very
badly and they were all completely wrong
because they talked about brexit
uncertainty which was complete nonsense
because actually all the uncertainty is
about our charade will benefit us and
about the terrible negative effects of
brexit which nonsense because again free
trade in town but that's got to be good
for us and most ordinary people
understood that and they went on
spending they had confidence and that's
what we we've seen in the figures in the
second half of the year and that
knowledge it today now the governor has
taken us through how the bank arrives at
these upgrades it's putting most of the
credit for the latest upgrade down to
the Chancellor's Autumn Statement and
the actions that he took there do you go
along with that assessment no I think
that's complete nonsense I mean the
Chancellor hardly change anything in the
Autumn Statement and nor did the bank
change marketing policy I mean half a
percent core durable so sir a we
absolutely agree I think the bank did a
decent job in supporting liquidity in
the actual turbulent Valen Valen tile
days you know just immediately after
breakfast but beyond that I don't think
they've really done much either either
either the bank or the Chancellor now
the bank's clearly quite relaxed about
inflation from what it was saying today
though a said Conway was pointing that
just before you came on air there are a
lot of input price increases now
certainly being faced by UK
manufacturers at what point would you
start raising interest rates well I
think the bank is now opposite sure
towards the higher interest rates over
the medium term if if deed as I think
it's even now getting growth of
too low I mean I think that the two to
three percent region it's now saying
growth will be it saying two percent but
it's in the region of reasonable growth
projections in my opinion but I think
it's likely to be higher and also the
the wage response may well be higher
than the three percent or so they're
projecting and the growth in the economy
numbers of the boom by the lower
exchange rate on exports hasn't really I
think being factored in they keep on
talking about how consumers you know
will be be muted because their real
incomes won't be rising so much but of
course when consumers are confident they
they will spend and investment is strong
and net exports are going to be strong
so they may well be looking at more of
boom and the more of a need to Rea is a
note alright Patrick we could leave it
there I'm afraid good to see us ever
Patrick Minford there from Cardiff
business school